peuple une victoire par exemple
à Marioupol. Reportage.
- C'est comme ça chaque année
à quelques jours du 9 mai.
Le centre-ville de Moscou
enfile son uniforme
à la gloire de la patrie.
C'est la répétition générale
pour le grand défilé militaire.
Sur l'avenue de Tverskaïa,
qui mène à la place Rougplace R,
l'armée parade avec
son équipement, ses chars,
ses blindés et même
ses ogives nucléaires.
Les Moscovites regardent.
Certains sont en extase.
"Ça ne me fait pas peur,
dit Valeria en pointant
un missile balistique
derrière elle. Au contraire,
c'est la force, c'est la
protection et c'est rassurant."
"Dans notre pays, chaque
génération a sa guerre
à défendre", dit Galina,
drapeau communiste à la ma
Elle dit que ses parents
se sont battus à Berlin.
"C'est dans nos g-elle,
de combattre le mal."
Impossible cette année
de dissocier le patriotisme
ambiant d'une guerre qui leur
a été vendue comme nécessaire
et essentielle pour libérer
l'Ukraine du nazisme
et pour protéger la Russie.
Le politicien en exil
Gennady Gudkov parle
d'une espèce de psychose
collective nourriepar la propage
et dangereusement belliqueuse
du Kremlin.
Vladimir Poutine se sert
d'ailleurs plus que jamais
de la télévision d'État
pour brandir la menaced'une frae
sur les pays de l'Occident,
qui fournissent des armes à
l'Ukraine.
Dimanche, l'animateur vedette
Dmitri K même évoqué
la possibilité de rayer la
Grande-Bretagne de la carte avec
une torpille nucléaire géante,
vidéo à l'appui.
Mais on appuie le président
coûte que coûte. Dans les rues
de la capitale, tout le monde
affiche les couleurs de
cette guerre en vue du 9 mai. L,
un soutien presque obligatoire
pour les commerces, si l'on
se fie à cet homme qui décore
la façade de son m
malgré le fait que
sa propre fille a dû fuir
les bombardements en Ukraine.
Mais il préfère s'abstenir
de tout commentaire,
censure militaire oblige.
Russie est en guerre,
il faut la gagner à tout prix",
dit Nikolaï, qui ne montre
aucune empathie pour les civils
qui meurent sous les bombes.
"Des milliers sont déjà morts,
dit-il froidement. Un peu plus,
un peu moins."
L'imporn lui, c'est
de sauver les soldats russes,
et ce, alors que les rumeurs
de mobilisation générale
s'intensifient.
À quelques jours des
célébrations du Jourde la Victot
se réjouissent et sont
impressionnés par cette
manifestation de force, certains
se désolent de son.......
"Attaquer un pays voisin
qui n'a rien fait pour
nous provoquer est cruel",
dit Paulina, une des rares
qui ose exprimer son opposition
à la guerre.
"Comment peut-on se réjouir?",
dit-elle. C'est ni beau,
ni patriotique. Pour moi,
c'est do